THIS HOUR IN ROCHESTER,
MINNESOTA, AND WE WILL GO RIGHT
TO IT IF NEWS HAPPENS, AND IT
MADE.
MUCH HAS CHANGED IN THE PAST
THREE WEEKS, WE WATCHED
SLACK-JAWED AS A PROFESSIONAL
LAWMAKERS ATTACKED THE RULE OF
LAW.
WE HAVE HEARD SELF-DESCRIBED
ANTIRACISM ACTIVISTS EMBRACE
FULL THROATED RACISM ON
TELEVISION.
WE HAVE SEEN PEOPLE WHO CALL
THEMSELVES ADVOCATES FOR WOMEN
DESTROY THE LIFE OF AN ACTUAL
WOMAN FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
THE COUNTRY IS ALL BUT INVERTED
DURING THE DEBATE OVER BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S NOMINATION, IT IS
BEWILDERING.
IN CASE YOU ARE HAVING TROUBLE
KEEPING TRACK OF IT ALL, A
REMINDER, IT WAS ONLY A WEEK AGO
THAT DEMOCRATS ARGUED A SECOND
SENATE HEARING INTO BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S HIGH SCHOOL RECORD
WAS NOT ENOUGH TO FIND THE
TRUTH.
WE NEEDED A SUPPLEMENT TERRY FBI
INVESTIGATION AND WE NEEDED IT
IMMEDIATELY.
>> THERE NEEDS TO BE AN FBI
INVESTIGATION.
>> THE FBI IS AN AGENCY OF SWORN
TRAINED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> AT THE INDEPENDENT
PROFESSIONALS OF THE FBI DO AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> AN FBI INVESTIGATION IS THE
ONLY WAY TO ANSWER SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS.
>> Tucker: IT ALWAYS STRUCK US
AS A MINDLESS DEMAND DESPITE ALL
THE HYSTERICAL DEMANDS FOR IT.
EVERYONE INVOLVED HAD ALREADY
GIVEN SWORN STATEMENTS UNDER THE
PENALTY OF PERJURY ABOUT WHAT
THEY KNEW FOR THIS STORY.
THE TWO PEOPLE AT THE VERY
CENTER THAT HAD ALREADY
TESTIFIED BEFORE CONGRESS ON
TELEVISION.
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S LIFE HAD BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF SIX PREVIOUS FBI
PROBES, AND NOT ONLY WAS HE
CLEARED AND ALL SIX OF THEM, HE
WAS GIVEN ACCESS TO AMERICA'S
NUCLEAR CODES.
WE KNEW ALL WE WERE GOING TO
KNOW ABOUT AN EVENT THAT
SUPPOSEDLY TOOK PLACE 37 YEARS
AGO AND THAT'S WHY THE FBI SAID
IT HAD ZERO INTEREST IN GETTING
INVOLVED AGAIN.
AND YET DEMOCRATS INVOLVED IN AK
AND YET DEMOCRATS INVOLVED IN AD
FOR A NEW INVESTIGATION AND THEN
PROTESTERS SCREAMED AT PORT JEFF
FLAKE IN AN ELEVATOR IN THE
SENATE UNTIL HE AGREED WITH THE
DEMOCRATS.
SO WE GOT THE INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO TAKE A WEEK
BUT IT WRAPPED UP IN SIX DAYS,
BUT THERE WAS NOTHING TO FIND.
ALMOST FOUR DECADES AFTER THE
FACT THERE WERE VERY FEW PEOPLE
LEFT TO INTERVIEW.
NOT SURPRISINGLY IN THE END, THE
FBI DID NOT CORROBORATE
CHRISTINE FORD'S STORY.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS, DON'T
YOU?
THE FBI MUST BE INVOLVED IN A
COVER-UP.
A DIABOLICAL SECRET PLOT
ORCHESTRATED WITH THEIR VERY
CLOSE ALLIES IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE TELLING US.
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO DAYS AGO
WERE TELLING US THAT THE IS A
IMPEACHABLE ORGANIZATION, A
TIEBREAKER.
BUT NOW THE FBI AS PART OF THE
DEEP STATE.
>> OF THE INVESTIGATION WAS VERY
LIMITED.
>> THIS REPORT IS BLATANTLY AND
CLEARLY INCOMPLETE.
>> OUR FEARS HAVE BEEN REALIZED.
THIS IS NOT A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION.
>> IN YOUR VIEW IS THIS A
FULSOME AND EDIBLE
INVESTIGATION?
>> IT'S OBVIOUSLY A COVER-UP.
>> Tucker: OUR FEARS HAVE BEEN
REALIZED.
THE FBI IS WORKING WITH THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND THEY
ALWAYS HAVE BEEN.
IT'S A PLOT SO SECRET, WE
BELIEVE THE OPPOSITE IS
HAPPENING.
HOW IS THAT FOR CLEVER?
OTHERS ON THE LEFT SAY NOW WHAT
WE REALLY NEED IS FOR BRETT
KAVANAUGH TO TAKE A POLYGRAPH
EXAM, BECAUSE THOSE ARE ACCEPTED
BY SCIENCE.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH CAROLINA SAID THE
LIE DETECTOR WAS LIKELY THE
FIRST DEMAND IN A LONG LIST.
WATCH.
>> WANDA WEED DUNK IN THE WATER,
MAYBE YOU WILL BELIEVE HE LIED
ABOUT HOW MUCH HE DRANK IN
HIGH SCHOOL, THAT HE THREW ICE
AT A BAR, OR HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
TEMPERAMENT, THAT HE DOESN'T
HANDLE BEING DESTROYED WELL.
ENOUGH, ENOUGH ALREADY.
LET'S VOTE.
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T WE JUST
DUNK HIM IN WATER AND SEE IF HE
FLOATS?
IT WAS GOOD ENOUGH IN MEDIEVAL
FRANCE.
YOU KNOW ONE INVESTIGATION WILL
NEVER TRULY BE GOOD ENOUGH, AND
INVESTIGATION OF SOME KIND OR
DUNKING OF SOME KIND THAT LAST
THROUGH JANUARY 3RD OF 2019 AND
THAT'S WHEN THE NEW CONGRESS
WILL BE'S STOCK IN.
THAT'S THE REAL GOAL, OR IT HAS
BEEN.
WIN OR LOSE, HIS NOMINATION WILL
BE VOTED ON IT LOOKS LIKE IN A
FEW DAYS.
IT SEEMS LIKELY HE WILL BE
CONFIRMED BUT WE WON'T KNOW
UNTIL THE LAST VOTE IS CAST.
STILL, IT'S WORTH THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THE WORLD LOOKS LIKE ONCE
THIS IS ALL OVER, AFTER
KAVANAUGH'S CONFIRMATION VOTE.
THE LEFT HAS ACCUSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP PRESIDENT TRUMP
OF OVERTURNING NORMS AND
DESTROYING INSTITUTIONS, BUT AS
ALWAYS, IT IS PURE PROJECTION.
WHATEVER THEY ARE ACCUSING YOU
OF IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
AND IT'S TRUE IN THIS CASE, TOO.
THE LEFT JUST MOUNTED A FULL
ASSAULT ON OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THEY THOUGHT NOTHING OF TOSSING
OUT THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
YOU SAW ACTUAL U.S. SENATORS SAY
THINGS LIKE, THE ACCUSED HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVE HIMSELF AND
HIS THEY SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
THEN THEY TRY TO USE THE FBI AS
A WEAPON AGAINST THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS, AND NOT FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION TO THE
SAME.
THINK THIS.
THINK AGAIN.
THOUGHT LEADERS, EXCEPT THAT'S
NOT AN OXYMORON ON THE LEFT, ARE
ALREADY LAYING GROUNDWORK TO
PACK THE COURTS, SOMETHING THAT
HASN'T BEEN TRIED SINCE THE
1930s.
ADDING MORE DEMOCRATS TO CHANGE
THE BALANCE, THE SMALL
DEMOCRATIC OPTION AVAILABLE.
IT'S ONLY FAIR TO OFFSET THE
THEFT OF MAYOR GARLAND'S SEAT,
AND THE APPOINTMENT OF A TEENAGE
SEX OFFENDER.
GOING FORWARD, LOOK TO THE LEFT
TO DELEGITIMIZE ANY DECISIONS BY
BRETT KAVANAUGH OF THE COURT OR
EVEN DECISIONS IN WHICH HE IS
THE MAJORITY.
SOME STATES MAY DECIDE TO IGNORE
THE SUPREME COURT.
DOES THAT SEEM FAR-FETCHED?
MAYBE NOT.
LOOK WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
LAWMAKERS IN THAT STATE, THE
LARGEST STATE IN THE UNION HAVE
ALREADY MADE IT A CRIME FOR
CITIZENS IN CALIFORNIA TO ASSIST
IN THE ENFORCEMENT OF ANY
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW.
CALIFORNIA IS, IN EFFECT, IN
OPEN REVOLT AGAINST THE LAWS OF
THE UNITED STATES.
SUPPOSE THE SUPREME COURT WERE
TRYING TO CRACK DOWN ON THAT.
BRETT KAVANAUGH SITS ON THE